went to the doctors and got an emotional  support animal card I double blast  myself though because like I went to get  the dog so that I could take him places  but then I realized when I can't take  him places I'm antagonized by it and  like it freaks me out so I've actually  do require that that's how I found out  now I need two dogs so big to take  anywhere like you can't fly with this  guy it makes you nervous yeah you gotta  run a private jet he's just sliding  around it's gonna be a whole thing he's  scampering about the place you'd be  better off with a terrorist  they say you can't negotiate with  terrorist but you actually can what are  your needs what is the historic problem  that you're trying to address so I might  get an emotional support terrorist I  don't know  by my wife he don't cooperate